-Jennifer, you were telling me
how recently you tried
ax throwing for the first time.
You challenged me
to a little competition.
And I don't know why,
but I said yes.
So we're going to take turns
throwing axes at that target
which we found in the old
"Tonight Show" prop room.
[ Light laughter ]
10 points for the hat,
5 for the body, 2 for the legs,
and uno, as the French say,
for the hands.
[ Light laughter ]
We'll throw three axes each.
Most points at the end
is the winner.
I will take the first throw.
Stand back.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Drumroll ]
-Here comes daddy!
Hu-oh!
[ Audience groans ]
[ Cowbell ]
No, stop, hey!
Put that thing down.
Oh, my --
-Do I go now?
-We just killed
the stage manager.
Okay, don't worry about it.
It's fine.
It's totally fine.
Jennifer, you go.
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Cowbell ]
Gosh.
[ Drumroll ]
-Hey, Jimmy,
I just remembered something.
No!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait a minute.
Stop, stop, stop, stop.
-What?
-Stop, stop.
Can we take that off?
-What?
We have to take it off?
[ Laughter ]
-Just make sure --
-What?
-Make sure --
-Got a lot of wood there.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cowbell ]
Make sure you go for the --
the hat.
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheers ]
[ Audience groans ]
[ Cowbell ]
-Ugh.
I feel like maybe I should just
keep throwing until I win.
I don't know.
-I split it right down
the middle right there.
That is --
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
-Come on.
-Get away.
Oh!
-Oh, my goodness.
-Oh, my God!
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There we go.
I win, the champion!
-Oh!
Oh!
God!
-No! Stop, stop, stop.
Jennifer Lawrence, everybody.
"Mother" is in theaters --
Jennifer, stop -- on Friday.
Pedro Pascal joins us
after the break.
Come on back, everybody.
Jennifer!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ How do I feel,
kinda how the sky feels ♪
♪ Becoming sideways
like a side fill ♪